you know I hear a lot yeah but I hear
the same thing about Trump like how many
mistakes is he made like kovat ah kovin
you bring up kovat good sir well I have
I have brought receipts I would like to
bring you back to the article from the
Philly Billy pen where it says Philly
rebuffs trumps threatened esenin feds I
want to highlight this key provision
that the White House seeks to impose
federal involvement in this way after
months of abrogating its responsibility
to lead a federal response to covert is
both ironic and offensive Kenny said in
a statement
Oh rum how dare the president failed to
lead this country let me show you the
NPR fact-check Trump doesn't have the
authority to order States to reopen whoa
whoa wait wait wait hold on hold on I'm
so sick of it hold on drop it - what go
ahead drop it no no no don't don't drop
the the subject like drop the bomb dude
I'm like saying I'm rooting you on go
for when Trump said the buck stops with
me I have the authority every state said
nope you don't and we can do what we
want and Trump said no you need the
president's authority and they said no
and Trump said when you're the president
your support your authority is total
What did he say he said you're the
authority is total and they said no it's
not so Trump issued guidelines here's
what the states should do and they call
that abrogating right Donald Trump
doesn't have the authority to go to New
York and tell koma what to do he has
jurisdiction for over federal Manners
matters meaning when someone crosses
state lines yeah perhaps I don't even
know if he can act if he can act a
border controls between states I don't
think it's authority to do that maybe I
don't think so he can protect federal
buildings he can deal with matters of
federal law but the state's control
their own their own themselves yeah they
do so this is what you get April 14th
Trump doesn't have the authority to
order States to reopen now I know
they're specifically talking about
reopening but let me just say if Trump
doesn't have the authority to tell them
the real to reopen isn't it fair to say
he doesn't have the authority to tell
him do anything that's what they're
claiming now though that now they're
saying he should have led the coalition
but
didn't want to the hypocrisy is real and
the Democrats yep so you know what man
I've been dealing with this for years
where it's it started off very much as
look in the early years of Trump I think
he did some bad things notably hiring
John Bolton and everybody knows a
mistake good point and I have no problem
criticizing her I mean yeah the dude
said we were gonna be celebrating in
Tehran what does that she's literally
saying we're gonna invade Iran and yeah
insane
it's crazy any Trump had to go and hire
these people you know for whatever
reason I don't know why he did it
I don't know what's going on the
administration but over the past year or
so it's been getting somewhat better
notably I'll mention you know calling up
China and more specifically Afghanistan
so at this point like okay man whatever
I'll take what I can get but early on I
got I started off very much as this
trope of the liberal who's like stop
making me defend Trump I hear that a lot
but every time the media would lie I'd
be like no no no come on he's bad but
he's not that bad right now it's just
we've become so insane and desperate
we have moved well beyond stop making me
defend Trump and it's to the point where
I'm saying stop allowing you to you you
duplicitous snake you are lying about
everything it's not even about Trump
anymore yeah it's about the economy
whenever the economy does well it's like
well they actually the economy's bad
stock market as well well a stock market
doesn't matter stock market tanks look
at the stock market now my favorite is
where all the libertarians to defend
against you know the stormtroopers
marching through Portland man I thought
you wanted gun rights to go up against
an oppressive state it's like okay hold
on maybe maybe there's no oppressive
state maybe maybe there's no oppressive
believe about though
against their whole their whole system
and their whole fight would be null and
void so this is what this is what I'm
saying man look when when whenever I
have the conversation where someone says
I know you know like earlier
Ian was saying you know I'm seeing
people are saying that's you know the
federal agents are going out there and
attacking protesters and then right and
then fights are breaking out and that
other people are saying the protesters
are attacking the building it's like
straight up the protester attack in the
building right I just I just read the
bail bail in cat segment where it said
after 39 days
the first federal response right so I so
worse than you're complaining why won't
Trump do anything for 39 days then he
finally does and now they're all crying
and he's any the only thing he does is
protect the federal land that he there
well they did totally loud they did go
out of the building and march of the
streets the feds okay but I mean if
they're laying siege to this building
with with commercial-grade
you know fireworks riders those are
lethal yeah they're going out to Nick
arrest
purge the people that are actually
attacking the Troisi gene precision of
words what arrest you said purge Oh
purge the streets well yeah okay sure
whatever remove them from the area
because they were straight-up
attacking you no man bill look I I
thought I thought about this over the
past several years as I've talked to
more and more about civil war yeah I I
did a segment earlier today on my main
channel where I pulled up a bunch of
stories where over the past year longer
they've been saying civil war civil war
civil war non-stop yeah it's coming it's
coming it's coming
I mean look right a point where the
states are openly defying the feds and
rejecting their authority but I often
wondered to myself how hard would it be
to be like a moderate fence-sitter
when a civil war breaks out and you
don't know unless it happens right well
I gotta say though you you just said you
know the the feds coming in or they're
denying the feds coming in it's worse
than that they're letting their own
cities burn they are openly letting
these people kind of resting out letting
them out I don't even know why they're
arresting them why do they even arrive
but now that they're focused on the feds
they don't care yeah but look this is
the point I was gonna make I'm thinking
myself like if you want to be objective
and report on what's happening how hard
would that be in a civil war that's oh
I've been thinking about in past several
years would it come to a point where
violence breaks out and I can be like
this group in this group are doing these
things
the answer is it's impossible there is
no word to describe a neutrally for both
sides what this group of people in
Portland is are whatever there's no one
word and and I've thought about it as
you know there you know when I when I
try to record I usually just press
record and start talking but every so
often I'll say something like protesters
oh God
out there they're not right they're not
insurrectionists well they're protesters
when the the cameras are on and the moms
are out and they are getting their you
know look they're singing their their
black lives matter songs and that's what
people are sending me like well look how
can you defend the feds like look
they're peaceful there's 2,000 of these
people all singing together show the
video of the moms trying to break the
door down
I sent them that way and they're like no
no no I don't need to see any of that so
the point I'm making is there is no
neutrality right now none whatsoever
right now you have a group of people
sure we can call them that and they're
attacking a courthouse as soon as you
say that people are gonna beg you're
lying they're peaceful
you're lying they're protesters you know
what do you call them insurrectionists
or protesters rioters or demonstrators
whichever one you choose shows which
tribe you are because of your worldview
your perspective on who they are and
what they're doing I have a feeling most
people will look at them as rioters I'm
eyed it depends on what news they get if
you if you show them the video I'm sure
at this point that's what I'm saying I
don't know if it matters anymore you
send a video of somebody bashing a door
yet the response is gonna be oh well
where was that well no of course they're
fighting back the unmarked secret police
were snatching people up oh they'll say
there's no beginning middle or end
anymore it's just a mess it's instantly
justified in their heads like yeah yeah
sure that makes sense well it's like
they're just fighting the system it's
tribes now man you know and when it
comes to tribalism
there is no reason anymore it's join or
die that's all it is so now that the
state of war look in in Oregon you have
mayor Ted wheeler and he's told the feds
to get out they were just chanting the
other night F Ted wheeler there's
another mayor who's gonna be running in
November and this mayor has openly said
that she is an Tifa straight up straight
up Wow
Trump has said an tyfa is a terrorist
organization so what happens when the
mayor of this town becomes joins the
faction that is attacking the federal
building that trump has declared to be a
terrorist organization civil war yeah I
guess I'm
that's insane since sanity it's not the
same thing as fort sumter but I have to
wonder if the Civil War was like a
catalyst for unifying American
nationalism like they said yeah you know
it's it's a line from the movie national
treasure which is itself a national
treasure Nicholas Cage the man I will
agree he says before the Civil War they
said the United States are after the
Civil War they said the United States is
because the state the country is the
United Sates was viewed as a single
nation right I wonder if we're looking
at the unzipping now the so we've had
we've had our bell curve we're coming
off the end of this of this ride yeah
someone said to me today they they're
from another country they said hey you
know just looking from another
perspective I wonder if we're gonna
start calling it just the States of
America yeah instead of the United
States of America the federal government
collapses the states of their own
borders and everything ma so I mean
it'll be it'll be it'll be insanity for
a couple for a decade of just chaos
border checkpoints being set up
you know desperate you know well so
here's what I'm saying
if Oregon has rejected the authority of
the federal government mm-hmm if you
know Chicago is now saying the same
thing Philadelphia is saying the same
thing it's not necessarily at the state
level but Oregon is at the state level
yeah let me show you something else let
me see if I can where do I have this so
I have this pulled up there we go I got
a pulled up Greater Idaho perhaps a new
state I could still see every every
single time as the Idaho I just see Joe
Biden sniffing see the top right I can't
unsee that once you see it it's like
yeah it's great and I know greater Idaho
wood wood wood wood absorb the more
conservative areas but this won't this
won't change our primes that front what
is that from this is a OPB I think yeah
OPB Network no the map itself is that
the way it used to be or is that just
that's from this border for a greater
Idaho ovation okay there's also calls
for the state of Jefferson which would
be Northern California and like Southern
Oregon interesting yeah so this has been
talked about that the more conservative
areas would band together yeah but I'm
not sure that would actually saw
the problems happening right now the
problems are that you know the the the
tracks of this country you know the this
country's tracks have split so far
they're unrecognizable at this point and
all that matters is you bow to the tribe
is the orange man good or bad pick one
and if you try and be a lie out come on
show up you must be on the other side
end of story right how can there be an
election if everybody's if they're like
Trump is cheating they truly believe
that he is and then in Obama's and then
I I'm on the the other side thinking
that they're cheating so it's like I
could see both sides everyone thinks the
other they're just pointing fingers at
each other like you're cheater no you're
the cheater
everybody's cheating so how do we move
forward then as a united state matters I
don't think it matters I don't think it
matters who wins or loses if Trump loses
in my opinion based on everything I've
read and the news I've tracked and I've
been around the world and I think of
course I think I'm right Joe Biden is
gonna pull off of a TPP you know he's
gonna try and rejoin up with China yep
they're gonna sell off our industry
they're gonna strip the rights of
American citizens to international
corporations we already heard from Jack
Dorsey when I was on the Rogan podcast
when he said where our rules are for a
global community mom you remember
remember he was talking about where we
serve a global community so our rules
are more the UN is basically denounced
hate speech they've basically been like
oh you shouldn't allow hate speech what
we believe in liberalism and I mean that
in the true academic sense of the word
not the colloquial stupid you know
leftist right like the idea of the
consent of the governed freedom of
speech expression the right to life
liberty is put of that pursuit of
happiness are going to be gone I agree
that's why I'm so afraid of people
voting for Biden because they're blinded
to the bigger picture now think about
the other side their one chance to
defeat white supremacy they view America
as a colonial empire of genocide that
must be purged they believe that science
that time that schedules are all white
supremacy that must be abolished and
purged that I mean getting into that
conversation it just proves to me how
misguided and
I think all that matters is my thing
just they're just misguided for sure
misguided I see the left as a chaotic
destructive force yeah and they've you
know the putting it lightly but the
modern Democrats have essentially given
up and given in for power and the
leftists are taking the reigns and
trying to pull as hard as they can they
haven't made as many games as they want
what's happening in Oregon is a huge
advantage for them but they can't win
anything because they have they offer up
no cohesive structure for anything I'll
tell you what does happen though when
this fight breaks out between those who
believe in this country and those who
don't
china what they're gonna they're gonna
finally pull the trigger
China won't there won't need to be a war
if America collapses from within that's
a good point so maybe this is how we
avoid Thucydides trap America is done
and that's why people like Mark Cuban
won't speak up about Hong Kong because
that's their exit strategy America can
collapse the dollar can tank silver and
gold are spiking stocks are spiking and
he can dump his money to China and then
when the collapse happens he'll still be
rich not him I'm calling him out partly
because the Ted Cruz thing I don't know
what is you know if he said anything
about China um I want to be careful
about dragging individuals I know all I
know for sure but how many billionaires
are like my financial interests are in a
bunch of different countries I'll be
rich forever you know and how many
Americans are gonna be just left to live
in the wastes better we got to be we got
to be aware we have to talk we got to be
we have to be talking we have to be open
we have to be you know explaining you
know it makes me think of Darrell Davis
on a grander scale like he went and to
his own like threat of his own life
like he could have been killed doing
what he was doing but he went out there
to talk to these people and show them
that you know he there's no it's not
even that complicated it's not even that
companies like talk to him I'm gonna go
talk to it this is the guy who D
radicalized 200 Klansmen famous blues
musician a black man who went to a bunch
of Klan meetings yeah amazing guy and
then what happened when he went to my
event in Philly they called him they
called him a white supremacist and
refused to talk to him right exactly and
he made they had this viral post on
Facebook where he was shocked
how was it that he was able to walk up
to Klan members you know and they were
like what do you have to say that scares
me but then we went to the anti-fog they
were like get out of here you white
supremacist fu right and he was like I
can't believe it or how about the the
police officer in Seattle I believe it
was where he's you know he's talking and
he was standing there and I guess a
younger a black person walked up to him
and was like you know hey can I talk to
you you know you're obviously we're
saying like defund you can you talk to
me and he's like I really want to I want
to talk to you but every single time I
try to some white and Tifa person comes
up and at that moment right then yeah a
white ant Aoife person was like don't
talk to the police how dare you talk to
the police it's like you they can't even
have their own voice and it's a cult it
is a cult
they're there to indoctrinate all these
people and convince them that you know
racism is real no it's not even about
any of that
it's it's kind of like applying a you
have a structure and it's made of wood
and you want it to come down and so what
they're doing is they're taking a
corrosive and they're rubbing it on
support structures and then you sit back
and wait and eventually the supports
become too weak and the whole thing
comes down yeah I was in San Bernardino
there was a protest it was far-left
versus Trump supporters and I was just
filming I walked over to the far left
side and there a bunch of people in
black blocks wearing all black standing
there and I said can I and you guys want
to tell me what's going on and then all
of a sudden an organizer ran up and
started chanting just chanting I don't I
remember exactly what they were chanting
but they're just mindlessly chanting Mic
Check Mic Check Mic they do yeah
if you as a journalist try and walk up
to a group that doesn't have the ability
to violently crush you like they do if
you're filming they'll be like get them
get them they'll beat you up for having
a camera yeah they just chance that no
one can talk to you like you're imagine
with the cop yeah it's not about any
real idea it's not about making anything
it's about literally just applying a
corrosive that destroys the support
structures the bonds of a functioning
society yeah and you know the problem is
hmm there's no one trying to repair it I
mean there it's an exaggeration there
are a few there are people like Jordan
Peterson there are people like Brett
Weinstein people like us
I mean I'm seeing I'm seeing these new
politicians that are coming Shon Parnell
for example now gates I think yeah
they're out there my someone in Jersey
who's running also those really awesome
got a good platform but I see this new
wave of politicians that are coming out
and that's what we need we need this I
think you keep saying it's it's you
think it's too late
I hear you Tim ten ipiria ten of the CDC
is intersection Allah stand they
demanded that the federal government
declare that racism is a national health
crisis right and then oh the problem is
articles are coming out right now that's
saying they're flooding all the numbers
and so it's like they can't juggle so
many lives or lies excuse me
they can't juggle all these lies before
they start dropping them all and being
like oops you got me lying I disagree
okay when you have fun when when when it
turns out that you you have about 10,000
employees of the CDC and 1,200 have
signed a document demanding a national
health crisis on racism which makes
literally no sense correct has nothing
to with the CDC you've already got an
ideological infection throughout your
nation worse than you realize it's like
seeing one Roach on the wall and going
it's just one roach it's fine and
ignoring it and then a year later you're
done and you could have done something
about it but the problem was this was
decades ago like you mentioned that
document on whiteness you know from the
Smiths from 1990 yeah those ideas right
nineteen I'm like wow I didn't know any
I was a chaos a little kid yeah so now
we've all grown up and surrounding us as
we are all the support structure of
American ideals the Constitution the the
Bill of Rights all the amendments we are
surrounded by people whose who have no
logical structures in their brains to
actually draw conclusions they think
time is racist it's meaningless they
think racism as a health crisis that
must be declared they think climate
change is racist they have these
nonsensical insane ideas like two plus
two equals five and I'm not exaggerating
there's a big Twitter threat from these
people explaining how math doesn't make
sense because it's actually white
supremacy the argument is that these are
they say clearly 2+2 doesn't always
equal four that's wrong because two
apples plus four oranges does not meet
you know plus two oranges do not equal
four apples what they do is they
manipulate misrepresent
and confuse to fracture the bonds of a
functioning logical structure and all
that will lead to is breaking down
so when ten percent were like apparently
now I'm seeing some talk about filing
FOIA requests against the federal
government to figure out who's doing
this weird intersectional ism mm-hmm
I was reading something that said that
once you reach ten percent saturation of
an ideology that's enough for them to
take over the whole system especially
when you realize that religious people
in this country aren't actually devout
religious if I'd be willing to bet that
if you took the average Christian and
place them next to the average
intersection list the average Christian
would be a regular kind of chill
American who probably isn't gonna preach
to you but the intersection list will
literally punch you in the face if you
don't get on your knees for you know
racial justice they'll bash when the
face and they'll call you a Nazi yep
so you compare who is truly ideological
intersectional list throughout this
country overwhelmingly are preaching the
gospel of their new well I'll call a
cult yeah and they're infecting every
every layer
how many corporations have come out
against this I think it's a religion no
how many how many member cult members do
you need to then it I don't register
anyway I'm pretty sure that's an actual
number though and I'm pretty sure they
have their new religion I think this is
I think the reason it's grad graduated
now to a religion is because they don't
have a personality it's literally just
it's an ideology that they worship you
know that is it's got its got all yeah
it's it's it's I don't want to say it's
a religion because religions actually
are something very are relatively
different historically yeah but they're
definitely some they're definitely in
the same structure of what a religion is
you know there are non-theistic religion
you know what their Idol is Golden Calf
you were close a golden participation
trophy yeah I think it should be a
Golden Calf I think we should make the
Golden Calf of intersectional ISM that
would be the perfect symbol for them
figure out a way to get them to adopt it
no I like cows they're cool yeah but do
you know that references yeah of course
yeah yeah was it was it a calf it was a
golden yeah yeah whose ground into
powder and they were made to drink it oh
that's weird yeah oh no he did not get
keep that Idol there you know Israelites
thanks for checking out this clip from
the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the show
live Monday through Friday at 8 p.m. if
you want to catch the full show tune
into this channel subscribe hit the like
button or check us out on iTunes and
Spotify and we will soon have this
podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you